greetings 3abn family and welcome to
another 3abn today Bible q a my name is
Ricky Carter and I'll be your host today
well we've got another hour packed of
your Bible questions and we also have
the answers from God's word are you
ready all right well I want to introduce
you to our illustrious Bible student
panel I want to start off here to my
right have sister Shelly sister Shelly
welcome here thank you it's such a
pleasure to have this opportunity amen
thank you for your questions
and in the next just a shadow we have
brother Daniel welcome brother thank you
very much I'm glad to be here there's
great questions to ask today amen amen
and next to him we have Pastor Rafferty
welcome Pastor Rafferty good to be here
Ricky looking forward to the Bible
questions and the answers from the word
amen amen well before we get into our
questions we should open up our study
today with the word of prayer Pastor
Rafferty could you lead us in prayer yes
sure let's pray Father in heaven we want
to thank you for your word and for the
Holy Spirit that's promised to guide and
direct us we pray for each of the
viewers who pray for our own hearts that
will be removed and touched by the words
that you've given to us to guide and
direct our lives and we pray all of this
in Jesus name amen amen amen
well sister Shelley before I ask you
your first question okay I want to share
with our viewers how they can
participate all right
all right well you can part icipate one
of three ways
first ways you can email us at
bibleqa at 3abn.tv that's Bible QA at
3bn.tv or you can text us at
618-228-3975 that's 618-228-3975
and then for those of you who are on
Instagram you can share your questions
there as well at 3abn underscore
official that's 3abn underscore official
all right sister Shelley let's get to
your first question okay
how does one practically maintain the
righteous by faith experience and that
is Christ enabling you to righteously
mature and at not being yourself doing
it that's from Ryan okay Ryan that's a
great question I'd like to start off
because many people don't know what
righteousness by faith is that is a
covenantal
term of relationship it is how God
interacts with his people and relates to
his people it's how we relate to him and
righteousness by faith there's two
aspects of that the first is to be
justified by faith Christ's death
Justified us that means he basically it
was an act of God that he got rid of the
penalty for our sin he stood in as a
substitute now the second aspect of
righteousness by faith is to be
Sanctified to be separated from sin this
is a work of God that goes on throughout
our lifetime really I mean it's
something that he is doing through
Christ Living in our hearts by faith
through the holy spirit so you remember
that Genesis 15 6 says that Abraham
believed God and God what counted it to
him as righteousness he credited it and
we are credited with Christ's life his
death and that's how we're made
righteous by faith
so what we're looking at it's not some
people just think oh the penalty's been
paid I'm accepting Jesus as Savior no
we've also need to accept him as Lord
and go through this process of
sanctification Jesus is going to give us
the power to overcome sin
how do we maintain this all right First
John 3 7.
it says little children let no one
deceive you he who practices
righteousness is righteous
and so just as he is righteous then he
says in this the children of God are
made manifest and the children of the
devil he who does not practice
righteousness is not righteous so we
know that we must yield to God we must
submit to God and yield to the power of
His holy spirit of course what I would
say to you Ryan is when we study the
Bible don't try to do it in your own
strength ask for the holy spirit's
guiding when in Bible study is
indispensable to living a life of
righteousness by faith when we're
praying ask for the Holy Spirit to help
us with our prayer and to do the good
works that God prepared in advance one
thing
God's plan is total dependence upon him
so we've got to come as Jesus said in
Matthew 18 3-4 as little children before
the Lord and depend on him amen amen
thank you sister
all right brother Daniel I've got your
first question here you ready okay
I've noticed
yes I've noticed a new trend among
Christians which is to light candles
while praying is this biblical at all
this is from sefence in South Africa
all right there is nothing new Under the
Sun but we want we don't want Trends we
want to hear what God's word says so
what does the Bible have to say about
candles and interestingly the Bible does
not mention candles at all it speaks of
lamps and you can think of an oil lamp
little Basin filled with oil with a a
wick that burns and there's neither
command nor prohibition regarding oil
lamps or candles during prayer nothing
moral or immoral about candles but that
doesn't necessarily mean do whatever you
want so how do people use candles during
prayer and I've got three ways here and
the first one is that it kind of sets a
mood or enhances a feeling and prayer is
not a feeling
there's no nothing inherently wrong with
lighting candles but if you have to have
a candle in order to get to the right
mood or feeling for prayer then there is
something wrong with your prayer life
that candles are not going to fix
and the second reason people light
candles is to pray to Saints or prayers
for the dead the light a candle that may
represent them and speaking about what
the Bible teaches about what happens
when we die we recognize that there are
no uh you know that when we die we we
rest in the ground until the
resurrection and there's nobody that we
can light a candle for who is in heaven
our prayers don't go through Saints they
don't go through people our prayers are
to God himself amen and number three
some people use candles in prayer as a
ritual or tradition to maybe strengthen
uh strengthen their prayers
and you cannot strengthen the force of
your prayers with any rituals or prayer
mats or prayer wheels or candles I think
of what Jesus says in The Sermon on the
Mount Matthew 6 7 When you pray do not
use vain repetitions as the Heathen do
for they think that they will be heard
because of their many words there's
nothing that you can add to your prayer
to make it stronger
so how should you pray well let's go to
the lamp the lamp to our feet light to
our fat to our path and in second
Corinthians chapter 7 verse 14 you're
familiar with this verse If my people
who are called by my name will humble
themselves second chronicles second
chronicles thank you
get those two straight If my people who
are called by my name will humble
themselves and pray and seek my face and
turn from their Wicked Ways then I will
hear from heaven and will forgive their
sin and heal their land and so we have
the idea of repentance and turning from
sin so you can light a Thousand Candles
and have no repentance as a Christian
and your prayer will not have power but
you can pray in the pitch black and
freezing cold with a repentant heart and
your prayer enters the throne of grace
and has power and I want to end with
Psalm 141 verse 2 it says let my prayer
be set before you as an incense the
lifting of my hands as the evening
sacrifice we simply bring ourselves no
other things necessary just a willing
repentant heart amen amen thank you
brother
okay Pastor James I've got your first
question for you ready
could you please help me understand
First Corinthians chapter 7 verses 12
through 16. that's from Marie in Papua
New Guinea all right Marie this question
is not specific so let's just take a
look and see what we can find in these
verses First Corinthians chapter 7 12.
but to the recipe guy not the Lord if
any brother hather what has a wife that
believeth not and she be pleased to
dwell with him let him not put her away
the woman which hath and husband that
believeth not and if he be pleased to
dwell with her verse 13 let her not
leave him for the unbelieving husband is
Sanctified by the why first 14 the
unbelieving wife is Sanctified by the
husband verse 14 else were your children
unclean but now they are Holy Verse 15
but if the unbelieving depart let him
depart a brother or sister is not under
bondage in such cases but God has called
us to peace verse 16 for what knoweth
thou o wife whether Thou shalt say thy
husband or how knowest thou o man
whether Thou shalt save thy wife so
these are two important verses here I
think the first point that that Paul is
making that we can get out of this for
the council for believers is that if
they're married to unbelievers he
encourages them to stay married because
their influence can actually sanctify
the unbelieving family members in other
words the witness of a believing wife or
the witness of a believing husband can
leave the spouse and even the children
to the Lord and that happens all the
time now the point here is that the
family is our first missionary field the
Bible tells us very clearly that if
you've accepted Christ and the rest of
your immediate family has not accepted
Christ it's no reason to leave them now
we're not supposed to marry unbelievers
but if you find yourself already married
God has given us counsel here that we
should have try to have a sanctifying
influence on the rest of the family that
may not be believing uh there's another
Point here that I think wants some
consideration and that's verse 12. it
can be a difficult one for some people
but to the rest he said speak not I
excuse me speak I not the Lord
now this phrase has been used to suggest
that some of what Paul was saying was
from God and some of what Paul was
saying was his own opinion right and
I've heard pastors actually suggest that
but that's not actually the point here
Paul is actually quoting from the Old
Testament in First Corinthians chapter
7. he's quoting from the Old Testament
and then he goes on to actually share
some things that he believes are
inspired of God and we picked this up in
verses 10 and 40 of the same chapter I'm
just going to read these verses quickly
and under the married I command yet not
I but the Lord let not the wife depart
from her husband that's verse 10. he's
quoting the Bible the Old Testament
verse 40. but she is happy if she's so
abide after my judgment and I think also
I have the spirit of God so Paul was
actually speaking under the spirit of
God but his Judgment of the spirit of
God was not the old testament which was
which he was at times quoting amen amen
thank you brother okay sister Shelley
here's your second question okay
I've been studying Galatians and I need
to understand Galatians chapter 3 verse
13. what does it mean cursed is everyone
that hangs on a tree that's from Sue in
Arizona Sue I just so appreciate your
heart to know the word of the Lord let's
look at Galatians chapter 3 we'll begin
with verse 10. for as many as are of the
works of the law are under a curse for
it is written cursed is everyone who
does not continue in all things which
are written in the book of the law so he
tells us what law is talking about this
Deuteronomy is the book of the law to do
them and then he says verse 11 but that
no one is justified by the law and the
sight of God is evident for the just
shall live by faith yet the law is not
of Faith but the man who does them shall
live by them Christ has redeemed us from
for the curse of the law having become a
curse for us for it is written cursed is
everyone who hangs on a tree so Paul
here is quoting from the book of the law
from Deuteronomy 21 22 and 23 and it
says if a man is committed to sin
deserving at death he's put to death and
you hang him on his tree on a tree his
body shall not remain overnight on the
tree but you shall surely bury him that
day
so that you do not defile the land which
the Lord your God is giving you as an
inheritance for he who is hanged is
accursed of God so that's what he is
quoting he's from the book of the law
what happened after an execution the
rabbinical teachers say that the corpse
could be hung on a tree to bring
humiliation and public display of the
consequences of their Disobedience
Christ died the most humiliating death
there was naked hanging on a tree even
though he had not sinned but God would
not allow them to display that corpse
long they could not leave the body there
overnight it had to be buried before
Sundown and then he goes on in Galatians
3 14 and says
uh that the blessings of Abraham might
come upon the Gentiles in faith that we
might receive the promise of the spirit
through faith so he's saying Christ who
hung on the tree for us
pay that penalty for breaking God's
Commandments God's law he took our sin
that we might become the righteousness
of God in him amen amen thank you sister
okay brother Daniel I've got a second
question here for you
it says in Daniel chapter 3
when the three Hebrew worthies would not
bow down to Nebuchadnezzar's statue and
were thrown into the fiery furnace that
was heated seven times hotter where was
Daniel
the Bible makes no mention of him being
there that's from Heather in Lindsay
Ontario Canada
all right Heather I am glad you're
studying The Book of Daniel Jesus tells
us that we should study the Book of
Daniel Amen it's true you cannot read
through this book and get to Daniel
chapter 3 without wondering where was he
and the answer is the Bible doesn't tell
us
so people have guessed and ultimately
our guesses are speculation on they
might be based on good wisdom uh either
he was there
or he was not there
and uh we look at Daniel's life and in
chapter one he stands firm for what he
believes in Daniel chapter 2 he is
willing to stand up and confront a king
chapter four he confronts a king chapter
five he confronts a king chapter six
he's willing to die for what is true and
so I certainly don't believe he was
there either in a role of facilitating
or participating and one of his
contemporaries Ezekiel says that he was
a righteous man but the thing is that
the text is completely unconcerned with
that question it doesn't even mention
the fact that he wasn't there and Daniel
who wrote the book certainly knew where
he was and he could have told us but
under God's inspiration he left that
unsaid there's a deeper meaning though
to the fact that Daniel is absent and
his absence does something in the story
instead of focusing on him our attention
is focused elsewhere it's focused on
three young men hananiah Michelle and
Azariah in chapter 1 and 2 Daniel is the
one who appears to be the leader of the
group Daniel purposes in his heart
Daniel is the one who suggests a special
diet he's the one who suggests a 10-day
test in chapter two he's the one who
goes to ariak the the Executioner and
he's the one who speaks before the king
but in Chapter 3 The Three stand alone
without the presence or strength of
their leader and this is a lesson that
is there for you and me that you will
face the opportunity I will face the
opportunity to make and display my own
decision and I thank God for Godly
leaders but in this situation these
three stand without their leader and you
and I will have to make the same
decision not following the lead or
leaning on the strength of a pastor or
teacher Bible teacher parent friend or
television network
dare to stand alone is how the old song
goes and the truth though is we never
stand alone and I want to end here with
what Paul said he had an experience in
second Timothy chapter 4 verse 16 and
17. he says at my first defense no one
stood with me
oliversook me May it not be charged
against them but in verse 17 he says but
the Lord stood with me and strengthened
me amen and so where was Daniel
the point is that you get to make the
decision that those three friends made
to stand for Jesus and may the Lord help
each one of us each one of us here and
you there to be loyal whether we're
alone or surrounded by friends
amen thank you for that answer brother
okay pastor Rafferty I've got your
second question and this is your
opportunity to give us a four-minute
answer okay
here's your question
please help me understand Revelation
chapter 20 verses 9 through 10 that says
the wicked will be thrown in the Lake of
Fire tormented day and night forever and
ever
it seems illogical that God has two
kinds of eternal life one in paradise
and another one in the Lake of Fire
that's from Theo
great question Theo and you are correct
that is illogical and it is unbiblical
because the Bible says the wages of sin
is death
amen not Everlasting burning so the gift
of God is eternal life and if we don't
receive the gift of God we don't have
eternal lives even a life even in flames
in in the flame of fire so the most
precious verse in the Bible John 3 16
gives these these two options uh God so
loved the world that he gave his only
begotten son that whosoever believes in
Him should not perish that's option
number one but have everlasting life
you've got everlasting life versus
perishing there are no other options in
the Bible and the Bible is consistent
with itself so whoever believes in him
doesn't perish and those who do believe
in him have everlasting life Jesus talks
about this in Matthew chapter 10 and
verse 28 he says fear not them which can
kill the body but are not able to kill
the soul
but rather fear him which is able to
destroy both body and soul in Hell
destroy is the word that's used here
there's no Everlasting burning or
everlasting life in any kind of form
that God is offering to those who reject
the gift of eternal life in Jesus Christ
but the issue with the text really is
this idea in Revelation chapter 14 of
forever and ever and ever we find it in
Revelation 20 we find it in Revelation
chapter 14 and it has perplexed many
people and others have built a false
theology around this phrase forever and
ever now the phrases used several times
in the Bible to denote or describe
events that have an ending one of the
best examples of this is Jonah chapter
2. Jonah says that he was in the belly
of the fish forever according to verse
six I went down to the bottoms of the
mountains the Earth with her bars was
about me forever yet hast thou brought
my life from from corruption O Lord my
God so the Bible says in the New
Testament that Jonah was actually down
there for three days and three nights
right but Jonah is using this
terminology forever because he's
describing an experience that was
terrible when we have these bad
experiences even if it's waiting a long
time for our food we might say well that
just took forever I'm so sorry it took
me forever to get here or just a long
time this is an exaggeration that is
used by human beings and God picks up
this language in the Bible to denote a
terrible experience a bad experience we
want it we want to really pinpoint this
you know um
over and over again like in first Samuel
27 verse 12 we're told that that phrase
is used to describe an event that ends
and yet it seems like a long time when
we think about Revelation chapter 14 for
example let's just look at a couple of
verses here verses 10 and 11. the same
shall drink of the wine of the wrath of
God which is poured out without mixture
into the cup of his indignation and he
shall be tormented with fire and
brimstone in the presence of the Holy
Angels and in the presence of the lamb
and the smoke of their torment ascends
up forever and ever and they have no
rest day nor night who worship the Beast
and His Image and whosoever receives the
mark of his name see if hell was a
continuing
Eternal experience it would be a
miserable experience even for the sake
because this verse says it takes place
in the presence of the Holy Angels and
in the presence of the Lamb so we know
that's not the case in fact Malachi 4
tells us that the wicked are going to be
burned up and they will be ashes under
our feet and that's because God is a
merciful god at the same time we need to
recognize that there is going to be a
hell for the wicked there is going to be
this experience that is so uncomfortable
it seems like it's taking forever and
the Bible uses this phrase to describe
this experience because it is an
experience that is well Isaiah 28 says
it's God's strange act so no there is
not an eternal burning hell and an
eternal Paradise there is only an
eternal paradise and hell is a torment
that ends with the wick of being
completely burned up amen amen thank you
Pastor Rafferty
okay well sister Shelly before I give
you your third question I want to remind
the viewers at home how they can
participate
well you can participate again with one
of three ways you can email us at
bibleqa at 3abn.tv that's Bible QA at
3abn.tv or you can text us at
618-228-3975 that's
618-228-3975 or you can those who are on
Instagram you can send your questions to
3abn underscore official that's 3abn
underscore official
all right sister Shelley I've got your
third question and this is your
opportunity to share with us a
four-minute answer
I've been a part of a Christian forum
for 12 years
I've been trying to share the truth
about God's Commandments and the Sabbath
but they believe the lie about the
Commandments being nailed to the cross
I've been kicked off three times but I
keep getting invited back
should I give up because I believe the
devil has been trying to block me from
completing my post
I do know of one person who has accepted
the truth about the Sabbath from my post
and I always pray over my posts for
guidance should I keep being so
persistent with my posts that's from
Rebecca in Oregon Rebecca I admire you
and I just have to say it is very
difficult to break through
preconceived opinions preconceived
opinions insulate people's minds against
truth I admire that you have been so
persistent let me suggest if you're
having a difficult time maybe you need
to look at your tactics first of all
make sure you're speaking the truth and
love if they're kicking you off maybe
there's something that you're saying
that boy when you put a text or
something people can take things so
wrong you don't want to be argumentative
use scripture to persuade and one thing
that I have found is that when you ask
questions you make people think so let's
quickly take a look Colossians 2 14.
walk up what got nailed to the cross
well we know Romans 6 6 says that our
old man was nailed to the cross with him
we know our sin but listen to this
Colossians 2 14. having wiped out the
handwriting of requirements that was
against us so what's wiped out a
handwriting of requirements against us
which was contrary to us he has taken it
out of the way having nailed it to the
Cross having disarmed principalities and
Powers he made a public spectacle of
them triumphing over them in it
so now when you see so or so that or
that it's a purpose statement so he's
saying this handwriting of requirements
got nailed to the cross
so here's the purpose that we're going
to follow
let no one judge you in food or in drink
or in regarding a festival or a new moon
or sad bus that's annual Sabbath which
are a shadow of things to come but the
substances of Christ so we know that all
of these annual Feast States these food
and drink offerings represented Christ
he was the body that casts the shadow so
here's how maybe you could do some ideas
for real quickly
um
ask a question where do we find the
handwriting of requirements against the
people that contain food and drink
offerings festivals an annual Sabbath
that pointed to Christ well we know
Exodus 24 7 the book of the Covenant
which was the what we call the old
Covenant it was civil and social and
ceremonial laws that served as a
constitution for the new country or
nation of Israel God layered that on top
of the Everlasting Covenant to help them
learn how to keep his Commandments and
what to do so we know the Commandments
were basically his Charter of Rights you
know for all of his government because
we see that in the New Testament as well
God repeated an enlarged these
Commandments in the book of Deuteronomy
so
what did what did these ceremonial laws
represent they were symbolic of Christ
Ministry
Deuteronomy 31 26 take the book of the
law put it by the Ark of the Covenant it
had all of these curses written in it
that were to be accursed against the
people who broke God's Commandments but
they put it he had
Moses put it on the side of the Ark you
can ask uh well does that suggest it's
temporary when the Ten Commandment law
of God was inside the ark this is on the
outside just ask questions because we
see that the Ten Commandments Hebrews 8
8 through 10 the New Covenant God has
never
never abrogated his Ten Commandments
Lord you can just say didn't Jesus die
for PA you know to pay our debt for
breaking those ten commandments so if
God did plan to do away with his Ten
Commandments which no scripture says
amen wouldn't Jesus have died in vain
ask questions amen amen thank you sister
all right brother Daniel I've got your
third question and here's your
opportunity to share with us a
four-minute answer
can you explain First Corinthians
chapter 5 of verse 5.
how can we turn over someone to Satan
should we not pray for our weak brothers
and sisters instead of handing them over
to Satan also the rest of the verse is
weird
that's from Maurice in
Beauty oh how do you say this in city
name
would you oh I can't say that but yeah
Burundi all right turning someone over
to Satan do I have that Authority and
doesn't that sound a little extreme so
let's look at the text First Corinthians
chapter five and I'm going to start in
verse one
it begins like this and I'm going to
emphasize a few words as I go along here
it is actually reported that there is
sexual immorality among you and such
sexual immorality that is is not even
named among the Gentiles that a man has
his father's wife and you are puffed up
and have not rather mourned that he who
has done this deed might be taken away
from among you so stopping right here
this is dealing with open sin in the
church it's reported it is blatant it is
invasive and destructive this is not
just any problem with a Believer but
something serious and the church for
their part is puffed up they're proud
they're celebrating their tolerance of
sin well rather than celebrate the
response is this Paul continues in verse
4. it says in the name of our Lord Jesus
Christ when you're gathered together
along with my spirit with the power of
our Lord Jesus Christ and here's the
part you asked about deliver such a one
to Satan for the destruction of the
flesh that his Spirit may be saved in
the day of the Lord Jesus now notice
here that the purpose is salvation amen
destroying the flesh now this is not the
Flesh of the body dealing here with the
carnal flesh that is in opposition to
the spirit and so this then illustrates
how we are to deal with uh with serious
discipline in the church and Paul
mentions gathered together in the name
of Jesus so that's in prayer and with my
spirit that be with Godly counsel now
the truth is there's only two spiritual
kingdoms there's a kingdom of God in the
Kingdom of Satan and if you leave the
kingdom of God you naturally are in the
Kingdom of Satan and you will become an
influence to others so this defiant
sinner here in in Corinth had by his own
conduct withdrawn himself from the
kingdom of God and therefore also from
the body of Christ and so as a last
measure of discipline in the body of
Christ this was to be recognized by his
official removal from the church
essentially simply honoring his decision
to reject Christ
and isn't this what God does for us as
well when you go to Romans chapter 1
take verse 24 and 26 and 28 and you hear
these words God gave them up to
uncleanness God gave them up to vile
passions God gave them over to a debased
mind
God allows people to make a choice and
experience the results of that choice
and Paul is not speaking theoretically
when he gives us advice if you turn to
First Timothy 1 19 and 20 he shares an
experience that he had I'll pronounce
this wrongly perhaps himanius and
Alexander had rejected the faith and
conscience suffering shipwreck of faith
and he says whom I delivered to Satan
that they may learn not to blaspheme
essentially Paul says that they had made
their decision to turn away and there
was nothing more he could he could do
for them and so he allows them to go the
direction that they chose
so shouldn't we pray for our weak
Brothers instead of handing them over to
Satan absolutely this is not an either
or situation if someone places
themselves in the Kingdom of Satan then
it is our responsibility to pray for
them first Timothy 2 verse 1 this is
right after Paul talks about the
harmonious and Alexander he says this
therefore I exhort first of all that
supplications prayers intercession and
giving thanks be made for all men so if
you know somebody who has turned their
back on God and on the body of Christ
keep praying for them don't give up just
because they've walked away amen
thank you brother
all right Pastor James I've got your
third question okay
please explain Revelation chapter 8
verse 10. is this supposed to be an
asteroid that's from a viewer from
Michigan that is a great question if
you're from Michigan Revelation chapter
8 verse 10 and the third Angel sounded
in there fell a great star from Heaven
burning as it were a lamp
and it fell upon the third part of the
rivers and upon The Fountains of waters
you know the Book of Revelation is
written in symbolic language and this is
especially true of Revelation chapter 8
and 9 covering the trumpets numbers one
through six so these uh scriptures in
the Bible need to be identified by other
portions of the Bible unless they are
literal and there are principles that
you can follow to identify whether
you're looking at a Bible verse that's
literal or whether you're looking at a
Bible verse that is symbolic now we
understand these bible verses to be
symbolic in the Bible Satan is likened
unto a star that fell from heaven Satan
and his angels are like and then the
stars in Revelation chapter 12 and verse
4. the Bible also Likens a lamp to the
word of God in Psalm 119
verse 105 and Matthew 25 verse 1 talks
about the the ten virgins with lamps now
the third part symbolizes those who are
deceived by Satan in Revelation 12 verse
4 the third part of the Angels were
deceived by his lies and then rivers and
Fountains of water symbolize people who
have received the gospel people who
received the waters that were flowing
like rivers of waters the woman at the
well the Samaritan woman Jesus promised
her that the gospel would be like Water
of Life that would she would never
thirst again
so the context of these verses really
are are following a history and the
history begins shortly after the
Ascension of Christ to Heaven verse 8
reveals and symbols the destruction of
Jerusalem that was prophesied by Christ
in Matthew 24 verse 9 the fall of the
Western Roman Empire again a symbol of a
great Mountain burning with fire a
mountain in the Bible can symbolize a
kingdom or a government according to
Daniel chapter 2 and verse 10 reveals
the compromise of the Christian church
in the early centuries and you see these
events following in history the devil
uses a guise of Christianity he burns
like a lamp he comes into the church
professes to believe the the Bible
deceives Christians who compromise their
faith and stop staying faithful to the
word of God and if you'd like a more
detailed study on this you can look for
our program called salvation in symbols
and signs it's all about salvation it's
all about Jesus but it's in symbols and
signs I believe that the Book of
Revelation is the the revelation of
Jesus Christ not the revelation of the
Antichrist and that it's a revelation of
the Plan of Salvation it's it's you it's
uh depicted in symbols and signs and the
rest of the Bible helps us to understand
those symbols and signs and therefore
helps us to follow what we call
historicism a revelation of history from
the early Apostolic age all the way down
to the second coming of Jesus Christ and
into the new Heaven and the new Earth
amen thank you Pastor Rafferty all right
sister Shelley I've got your first your
fourth question excuse me
and here it is
why are there three persons in God
wouldn't simplify our teachings to have
to testify of only one person
that's from Howard in Lakeport
California
well Howard probably
the godhead
has always existed as three persons
according to the Bible there are 58
triadic scriptures that are talking
about God the father son and spirit and
we teach what the Bible teaches so we're
not trying to simplify this but I want
to
kind of walk you through something
what helped me a lot is when the Lord
showed me this as I was studying
it's so hard for us to understand the
co-essential
co-equal nature of a three in one God
and I've really stumbled around trying
to explain it in the past but one day as
I was studying that the holy of holies
was a cube and that the New Jerusalem
was a cube
what's a cube it's a number time it's a
number times a number it's it's uh one
of the equal numbers times each other
and all of a sudden it hit me
one times one times one equals one
it isn't God the father plus you know we
usually are trying to explain it and
people are saying oh there's three Gods
no it's one to the third power it's the
power of three if you know the algebra
it is one times one times one equals one
one's the only number that can be
multiplied by itself and still be the
same number or the only one that can be
divided when Jesus came here he was
divided from the father for a moment but
he was still one he was full of the
fullness of God and it's it Colossians 2
9.
what Paul said is the fullness of the
godhead dwelt in him bodily but I wanted
to point out the scripture of God you
know and God uses that multiplication
formula in other places a man and a
woman become married and it's one times
one they're one right they shall be one
flesh but
I want to point out one thing about the
holy spirit because he is the one most
people don't understand and that is he's
declared to be holy omniscient
omnipresent omnipotent he's as much a
part of creation as he was as we're the
father and the son and he was there to
help raise Jesus so God's plan is
includes the three in one
that we should depend on him totally
amen thank you sister
all right brother brother Daniel I've
got your fourth and final question here
respectfully
how do we handle differing viewpoints
within the church that's from Sue
I thank you for the way that you ask the
question and I believe that part of the
answer lies in the question and that is
respectfully
we are to make a distinction between
issues and people we're to treat people
with love and we're to treat issues with
truth with meekness and godly fear so
how can there be so many uh
disagreements on things that appear to
me to be so clearly expressed in
scripture and there's no shortage of
issues that divide us but the answer
comes I think in Jesus's prayer on the
night before he died
he's praying there in John 17 and he
asks Lord or father I pray that they
will all be one
not a false Unity where they abandon the
truth but they will be truly United and
Paul picks this up in Ephesians chapter
4 verse 13 and 14 he wants us he tells
us to come into the unity of Faith Unity
of the faith and knowledge so not just
Unity of Faith but also Unity of
knowledge no longer carried around by
every wind of Doctrine now we all have
varying levels of Christian maturity so
Unity will not always be represented in
immediate uniformity but we are to
continue growing growing in the grace
and knowledge of our Lord Jesus Christ
second Corinthians 3 18 says as we
behold his glory we are changed into his
likeness so we should come more and more
into the truth and accept it and reflect
it so why are there differences because
we have an enemy who wants the exact
opposite of what Jesus desires Jesus
wants unity and truth and so the enemy
sows seeds of confusion and conflict to
weaken our witness and to divide and
conquer so what should we do in this
fight against the enemy how do we deal
with those differences
Romans chapter 14 and the first 13
verses of chapter 15 give some
principles on how to deal with
disagreement not every divisive issue is
exactly like what they were dealing with
in Romans chapter 14. they were dealing
with diet and fast days and there are
some translations of the Bible that will
add some words to make it seem like it
was the issue of the Sabbath but that is
just not the case
and I won't highlight everything that
Paul gives here as advice but I will say
it's worthy of your study and usually we
will say those people over there they
need to read this chapter
but this is for all of us amen so Paul
does not answer the question who is
right in this chapter but he simply
answers the question of how do you deal
with people you disagree with and you're
going to have them
Chapter 14 verse 1 and 15 verse 7 are
good summaries of what Paul says and he
says welcome each other receive each
other as Christ has received you amen we
have got to learn to love each other
even when we disagree and then number
two dealing with disagreements we go to
John 16 13 where Jesus promises that the
spirit of truth will guide us into all
truth and so we have to ask Lord give me
the holy spirit so that I can rest and
not upon my opinions not upon Traditions
not upon popularity not on what is
convenient but upon what your word
teaches interpreted by the holy spirit
because Paul does remind us there in
second Timothy chapter 2 verse 15 that
we should rightly divide the word of
Truth we can come to the Bible and we
can misunderstand it didn't Satan use
the Bible himself all right so Search
the word of God not an occasional search
but really search it deep and ask for
God's help and amen amen thank you very
much brother
okay pastor Rafferty have you have your
final question here okay
okay on the June 6th episode of Bible q
a
one of the panelists said suicide is a
forgiven sin how is this possible
as a child I thought this was the
unpardonable sin that's from Alice in
North Carolina well Alice I'm guilty on
the guilty panelist I believe I was the
one who addressed this issue and I gave
an example of Samson you know who asked
the Lord that he could die among the
Philistines when he was brought there to
the temple and put his hands upon the
pillars and brought that Temple down
upon the Philistines now there are two
points here that I think really need
clarification the first one is that
neither suicide murder adultery nor any
other one of the breaking of God's
Commandments is the unpardonable sin so
suicide is not the unpardable sin the
unpardonable sin is turning away from
the Holy Spirit Jesus tells us that in
Matthew chapter 12 31 and 32 wherefore I
say unto you Jesus says all manner of
sin and blasphemy which would include
suicide shall be forgiven unto men but
the blasph me against the Holy Ghost
shall not be forgiven unto men and
whosoever speaks a word against the son
of man it shall be forgiven him but
whosoever speaks against the Holy Ghost
it shall not be forgiven him neither in
this world nor in the world to come
I think the second Point here is though
is that even though Samson asked to die
with the Philistines we know he did not
commit the unpardonable sin and turn
away from the holy spirit because his
name is included in the Hall of Faith
chapter Hallelujah Hebrews chapter 11
and it's verse 32. at the same time it's
important to recognize that suicide is a
sin
and one that needs forgiveness and it is
one that we need to be safe from yet
suicide can be forgiven just like any
other sin we we can't read the heart in
fact there's a study that's been done on
people who have survived suicide
attempts off the San Francisco Bay
Bridge and all of those who have
survived most of them regretted
committing suicide or attempting to
commit suicide just after they jumped
yeah so we don't know what takes place
once a person makes that choice we don't
know what takes place in the heart or in
the mind between the time they make that
choice and the time their life may end
or may not end but we do know from those
who have who have attempted it that
there's a regret and of course we know
regret is one of the ways that leads us
back to the Lord regret leads us to
repentance many times into turning our
hearts back to the Lord and asking God
to forgive us and so that's the point
the point is is that the unpardonable
sin is not suicide the unpardonable sin
is turning away from the Holy Spirit and
even Those who commit suicide can still
be open to the impressions of the Holy
Spirit and perhaps even at that moment
more open to the impression of the holy
spirit because they've just done
something that they regret could I add
something to that because my mother
attempted suicide several times as a
child when I was a child and I had no
father because my father was killed in a
plane crash when I was six she had two
little girls and she was a loving mother
and I couldn't figure out why
would anyone leave two little girls
alone in the world and it wasn't until I
went through a really difficult period
I remember one night I'd had vertigo for
a year and and everything was crazy in
my life and I remember laying in bed one
night and I felt so low and I thought
boy Lord I didn't think I could ever get
this low what if I could get as low as
mama and it scared me I wasn't thinking
about suicide but I I will tell you that
suicide is generally a lack of Hope when
someone my mother had cancer she was
afraid she was going to take up every
penny and it had run up all these big
bills when when people lose all hope
they do some crazy things and so please
take
very seriously if you hear a young teen
sounding hopeless or a young child we're
seeing so much suicide among young
people today please take very seriously
and and don't be judgmental and if
you've had a relative who's committed
suicide just know they weren't in the
right mind at the time they got to that
moment where momentarily they lost all
hope but I read the same study and it
said that people even who've been
prevented as they're about to jump off
have been the next day they're over it
it was a momentary it's kind of like
temporary insanity thanks for sharing
that amen amen thank you Shelly for
sharing that yeah well I've been blessed
by all these answers that we've received
today on our program amen and I hope
that you were blessed as well
you know I want to let you know that
we're going to be taking a break here in
just a moment but I don't want you to go
anyplace because we're going to come
back for some final thoughts from our
panelists so just look on the screen
here it's coming up next and you'll see
some information and let you know how
you can participate on Bible q a so we
will be right back
if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible q a
then tell your friends each Monday will
bring you a fresh program answering the
Bible questions you send us using God's
holy word to shed light on those texts
that seem difficult to understand to
have your questions answered on a future
program just email them to us at bibleqa
at 3abn.tv that's Bible QA at 3abn.tv
you may also text your questions to
618-228-3975 that's
618-228-3975 be sure to include your
name and where you live and then
watch3ab in Bible q a for answers from
God's word
well our time is almost up but before we
go I want to let's get some final
thoughts from our panelists sister
Shelley I'm gonna defer to Daniel
because he had something he wanted to
add to his all right yes indeed dealing
with uh First Corinthians chapter 5 and
turning someone over to Satan Paul's not
done with that story uh they're in First
Corinthians he's got another letter and
in his second letter he comes back to
this same situation in chapter two and
in verse five to seven he's dealing with
forgiveness and it turns out that the
experience of of letting this person
feel the experience of what is coming as
far as judgment goes gives him
opportunity of repentance and Paul says
the punishment has been enough
bring him back uh welcome him back in
and he's had an experience of change of
heart and repentance and so that's one
of the one of the beauties of allowing
people to go their own way is that their
heart gets changed I love that because
you know you see the same thing if for
example in Daniel 4 you know
Nebuchadnezzar's handed over to Satan in
a sense he's like a wild and crazy man
for seven years I don't know how long to
this brother we know from First
Corinthians to Second Corinthians
whatever amount of time that was but
seven years and then God reels him back
in you know and this is what we see in
Matthew 18 when God tells Christ tells
us you know how to follow gospel order
and deal with issues in the church you
know go one-on-one and then take another
brother and then take it to the church
and then treat him like a Publican and a
sinner you know or a heathen well how
did Christ teach treat the publicans you
know he reached out to them he sat with
them got criticized for eating amongst
yes yes so the idea that we let someone
be disciplined isn't the same as just
letting go of them and giving up all
hope for them it's allowing them to
experience the consequences of sin so
hopefully they'll realize well you know
God has something better than this amen
amen thank you very much for all of your
answers I've been blessed by that have
you been blessed by that I'm sure you
have been
well we're about out of time I want to
encourage you to join us next time where
we can get some more great answers from
God's word God bless
thank you
[Music]